whether they're from low budget action
flicks or hated adaptations of beloved
shows and games these martial arts
sequences leave a lot to be desired The
Karate Kid is one of the most well-known
martial arts franchises in the entire
world starting in 1984 with the film
starring Pat Morita and Ralph machio the
combat style of karate kid became
incredibly popular in Western countries
due to its depiction in the karate kid
making it one of the most influential
martial arts films outside of Asia the
Legacy weighed heavily on The Next
Karate Kid which was released in 1994.
this time around Ralph michiho was
replaced by Hillary Swank in a breakout
role as Julie becoming the newest pupil
of Mr Miyagi despite praise for the
film's lead performances its action
sequence says pale in comparison to the
first three films as seen in its
climactic Showdown after Julie's love
interest Eric is ambushed by fraternity
Brothers Julie challenges their leader
Ned to a fight even though the whole
thing is scored to Epic orchestra music
Julie takes Ned down without much
trouble at all his only retaliation is
to throw mud in Julie's face to Blind
her which lets him easily throw her to
the ground overall this fight lacks a
clever choreography and Stakes are made
the Karate Kid a pop culture phenomenon
he said
fighting not good
martial arts films tend to be
underwhelming when they feature
non-actors in their lead roles that was
the first mistake of the 1985 film Jim
Carter which was directed by Robert
Klaus and Stars Olympic gymnast Kurt
Thomas Thomas plays Jonathan carball a
man selected by the American government
to enter an international athletic
competition where the winner receives
whatever wish their heart desires Jim
Carter has gathered a cult following
since its release despite being listed
by Maxim as one of the worst movies ever
made the fictional martial art that the
film is named after is even sillier than
its name suggests chaining together
plenty of unnecessary flips and
ludicrous jump kicks nowhere is this
goofiness more evidence than in the
scene in which Jonathan is ambushed by
terrorists as the mob of goons are more
than willing to let him set up his
attacks with big acrobatic flourishes
they don't put it much of a fight either
once they're here to these guys are
staying down and when they hit once they
stay down combining gymnastics with
karate may not be the best idea for
self-defense in the real world and it
doesn't seem to have been the best voice
for the movies either
Hong Kong native Godfrey ho directed
over 100 movies that are often regarded
as the best of the worst with titles
like ninja Silent Assassin and Robo
vampire his 1993 effort undefeatable
Stars Cynthia Rothrock as Christie a
street fighter on the trail of the
serial killer Stingray and is full of
Ho's trademark no budget charm after
Christy teams up with Detective Nick
Demarco the two track down the Killer
and beat him to death in a warehouse
even though this climactic fight
sequence has satisfyingly gruesome much
of it involves slow motion punches that
weren't edited in post-production the
actors are just pretending like they're
kids on the playground Nick and Stingray
also lose their shirts for no apparent
reason other than to show off and both
make the most of every labored groan
thanks to its poor quality the final
fight garnered attention for the film
and it was eventually featured on an
episode of the show world's dumbest
undefeatable was elevated from a
forgettable B-movie to a viral cult
classic it may not be the best martial
arts film out there but it's certainly
one of the most memorable friends keep
an eye out for you Stingray
yeah
see ya
not to be confused with Miami Vice or
The French Connection
1987's Miami Connection as a reputation
for being hilariously awful this
low-budget attempt at a martial arts
flake was written directed and produced
by YK Kim it also stars as a member of a
band of Taekwondo practicing orphans
when a motorcycle gang of ninjas kidnaps
the lead singer it's up to the others to
rescue their friend and bring the band
back together Kim produced the film
independently casting his Taekwondo
students and hoping that the finished
product would interest the distributor
Kim later accounted to CNN a showed
Miami Connection to hundreds of
different Studios and distribution
companies Mayo said this is trash don't
waste your time in one scene the heroes
are confronted by the train tracks and
take out the members of the gang all on
their own this would be much more
impressive if most of the thugs weren't
just standing around waiting for their
turn to battle one-on-one the one Saving
Grace of this scene is the Epic 80s
synth music that plays over it the
Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles or iconic
Staples of 1980s pop culture originating
in comic books before making the leap to
Saturday morning cartoons in 1987. the
heroes in a half shell became icons on
TV screens around the world thanks to
memorable characters and entertaining
animated fights when the turtles were
adapted into live action the action
choreography had to get more creative
they were being played by human stun
performers and Suits after all while the
first film released in 1990 was of box
office success there were diminishing
returns by the time the third
installment rolled around the third film
which was released in 1993 underwhelmed
fans and critics the three call also
known as Turtles in Time saw
Michelangelo Leonardo Donatello and
Raphael transported back to feudal Japan
one notable and impressive fight
sequence to Pixar reptilian quartet
being attacked by a group of samurai the
fight proceeds awkwardly with the four
turtles separated as they each deal with
their equal share of adversaries sound
effects and cutesy catchphrases aside
this fight is missing the stakes and
interesting choreography that the TMNT
are typically known for
let's go it's Hammer Time
Mortal Kombat was one of the most
influential video games of the 1990s
thanks to its memorable characters and
over-the-top violence the success of
Mortal Kombats at arcades and on home
consoles quickly sparked interest in a
Hollywood adaptation which arrived in
1995. the first Mortal Kombat movie was
followed up two years later with a
sequel Mortal Kombat Annihilation while
the first film wasn't a critical darling
it was praised for his entertaining
action sequences which is not something
the second film could boast Mortal
Kombat Annihilation was a failure
critically and commercially with fights
that New York Times critic Lawrence van
gelder called quote deadly dull the film
doesn't even do justice to the
franchise's most iconic characters
Scorpion and Sub-Zero complete with
stiff actors and lackluster visual
effects this climactic battle is the
ultimate showcaser by translating video
games to movies was looked down upon for
so long another Mortal Kombat film
didn't come out until 2021 which mostly
restore The credibility of the
franchise's martial arts choreography
The Matrix was released in 1999 and
redefined action film choreography for
decades to come combining the
rochowski's love for martial arts films
was science fiction and Anime this
success resulted in two sequels shortly
after the Matrix Reloaded and The Matrix
Revolutions The Matrix Reloaded was
liked by many what is typically
considered to be a major step down from
the first film one of its most iconic
scenes known as the Burley brawl finds
Neo ambushed by endless hordes of agent
Smith clones the perfect opportunity for
the directors to Showcase their leveled
up choreography unfortunately the
scene's visual effects put a damper on
the potential for a well-choreographed
fight sequence as most of the scene
plays out like a video game cut scene
from the early 2000s agent Smith clones
a tossed around with Neo's plot armor
being shown off as he's swarmed by
assailants who barely lay a finger on
him aside from a few well-framed shots
the bulk of the scene is a barrage of
CGI and fast-paced action that lacks the
first film's extravagant detail
Smith yes
now there's more than one of them a lot
more
much like Mortal Kombat Street Fighter
is one of the most iconic game
franchises of all time with the expert
keko Chun Li being a series staple since
1991. there was a lot of pressure to get
the action right when Capcom co-produced
Street Fighter the Legend of Chun Li in
2009 starring Kristen Krug as a titular
martial artist in typical fashion for
video game movies Street Fighter the
Legend of Chen Lee was a critical
disappointment while Crooks Chun Li
never done so iconic costume another
iconic Street Fighter character does the
Spanish ninja Vega Chun Li and Vega face
off during the film in a sequence that
ideally should pay tribute to the best
part of the Street Fighter franchise to
make a long story short it doesn't the
scene is set at night making the
characters hard to see and the movements
even harder to track what it does get
right about Street Fighter matches is
that the two characters also spend most
of the match not actually hitting each
other
calling Dragon Ball Evolution and
martial arts film is an insult to fans
of both Dragon Ball and the martial arts
films green LED during the 2007 writer
strike fans were skeptical of
Hollywood's ability to capture the
action sequences from the Manga and
Anime franchise in real life and as it
turns out they were right to be worried
despite some major deviations from The
Source material Evolution at least
manages to hearken back to the origins
of Dragon Ball when Justin chatwins Goku
appeared in his iconic outfit to face
off against King Piccolo Terrible
Special Effects aside this martial arts
sequence doesn't have half the
excitement of any fight scene in Dragon
Ball Z instead the two spend most of the
fight trying and failing to hit each
other with energy blasts it doesn't get
any better when they finally do make
contact and fly into the sky via an
impressive wire work the awkwardly cling
to each other as they trade punches and
for most of the rest of the scene the
two of them rarely occupy the same shot
when it comes to terrible martial arts
films the Undisputed king of Steven
Seagal throughout the 1990s he actions
star gained a reputation for his
arrogant behavior off-screen and ever
since his appearances have been mostly
limited to director video releases one
such role was in tanbang's China
salesman a Chinese film in which Segal
seems woefully out of place
hey why don't you guys speak English
after a fight breaks out in the tavern
Segal finds himself in a battle with
none other than heavyweight boxing
champion Mike Tyson this Clash of Titans
was made to feel like The Showdown of
the century yet it unsurprisingly
features not a single moment of good
acting from anybody involved simply put
showdown of the century it is not the
two ends up moving so lethargically that
it feels like they're in slow motion
Tyson spends a significant amount of
time breaking things with his fist while
Segal and dramatic actual slow-mo slaps
Tyson in the ear it's a fun bit of irony
considering Tyson's history with ears
but it's not enough to make this fight
feel like anything more than a joke
and like Shyamalan has directed some
Stellar films including the Sixth Sense
unbreakable and split however his
creative slump in the late 2000s
included his greatest failure the 2010
live-action adaptation of avatar The
Last Airbender shyamalan's version of
what's considered to be one of the
greatest animated series of all time has
since become regarded as one of the
worst films ever made many scenes
throughout shyamalan's the Last
Airbender showcases lack of regard for
the animated series action choreography
but none more so than one notably awful
confrontation between Aang and Zuko it
started Zuko somehow failing to notice
Aang standing right behind him and only
gets more ludicrous as it goes the fight
scene that follows features plenty more
Awkward Moments between the two the
worst of which being when Zuko picks
aing up like a baby giving the Avatar
the opportunity to wrap his legs around
the Firebender and flip him to the
ground aside from that it's mostly
attacks that are so obviously
telegraphed you could see them coming
from a mile away
Bruce Lee was a legendary figure whose
influence extends well past the World of
Martial Arts and into pop culture as a
whole Lee's career included iconic films
that showed off as talents like Fist of
Fury and Enter the Dragon and his
untimely death in 1973 left a massive
void that producers were eager to fail
the desire for more Lee led to the
creation of the Bruce Plantation genre
in which look-alike actors would take on
the role of the Beloved fighter one
particularly bizarre Bruce floatation
flick called the Dragon lives again came
out four years after Lee's death and
starred Bruce Lee young sulang as a
version of the star who wakes up in Hell
during his time in the Underworld Lee
fights several other movie icons
including James Bond Clint Eastwood and
even Count Dracula one of the most
unbelievable and unimpressive fight
scenes in the film features Popeye the
sailor man who helps take down some
mummies after devouring a can of spinach
actor Eric sang tries to replicate
Popeye's cartoonish combat style but
many of the mummies he's up against
barely move at all
on top of that it really looks like any
of Popeye's punches are actually making
contact this is one crossover event
that's probably worth skipping
[Music]